je tiens à exprimer ma gratitude
c'est ce que révèle sur les victoires
mais c'est quand même connu dans is it
un grand succès les français on a le
droit d'exister
l'immigration n'est pas une chance c'est
un fardeau ou qui votons fn ou sont pas
des variables de cette politique qui
consiste à voler aux pauvres pour donner
aux migrants on y arrive plus en france
c'est plus possible de vivre en france
une fois de plus le front national à
jouer dans la cour des grands dans le
silence des campagnes on a donné de la
voix pour le fn 40% en moyenne deux fois
plus que dans les villes et on finit
toujours par se poser les mêmes
questions qui et pourquoi
alors direction rozoy le vieil au
nord-est du loiret un village de 400
habitants où le parti de marine le pen a
fait son meilleur score plus de 58% des
voix
ça tombe bien ce jour là le maire fait
d'une pierre deux coups la galette des
rois et les voeux notre rôle c'est
d'être aussi solidaire et c'est comme ça
que je vois le labeyrie aussi le conseil
municipal comme un endroit où on est
les gens les gens à vivre mieux au
quotidien la solidarité le mot qu'il
faut pour toucher le coeur des rosetta
qui se sentent si loin de tout et si
près du fn ça fait 40 ans qu'on a des
gens viennent nous promettre des choses
et kg est capable de les respecter
un jour où ça va péter épaulés par des
dunes
moi quand je fais quelque chose je le
tiens mais il y en a qui promettent
toutes les montres et la lune
ils ont même tabac de l'avant il avait
trente pour cent des gens qui votent qui
ne sont pas représentés à l'assemblée
nationale veut écouter profondément
injuste et c'est normal qu'il y ait des
réactions de la population futur et puis
ça va continuer de monter et agrandi
être en démocratie mais quelle il paraît
que ça n'a pas toujours été comme ça et
pour l'historique on nous envoie chez
jeanine l'ancienne institutrice qui a
été maire pendant plus de 25 ans la
commune était très communiste voter
communiste c'était quelque chose de
connu et mm anticlérical et vous de 800
arrivée des feux accusés mais enfin si
quand même des commerçants des artisans
des gens qui venaient de région
parisienne à l'époque des lotissements
et là on a vu le vote communiste
disparaître mais comme un peu partout en
france peut-être et voix socialistes
continuent encore les gens du centre
aussi enfin le milieu et puis la droite
bon mais tout d'un coup est arrivé ce
vote front national
on s'est demandé à quoi attribuer des
explications le maire qui ne vote pas fn
en a même s'il avoue ne jamais parler
politique avec ses administrés je crois
que le plus gros facteur le principal
facteur c'est le fait qu'en se sent
abandonné on se sent abandonnés pourquoi
parce que on n'a aucun avantage par
rapport à nos voisins d'île de france ou
même du loiret si on va vers orléans
les salaires sont plus bas le chômage
est plus élevé en plus on a subie dans
les années 70 un véritable pillage des
territoires des lotissements qui ont
effet n'importe comment
les infrastructures compact est mise en
place
les structures industrielles qui n'ont
pas été mises en place eh bien on
trinque pour ce qu'ils étaient payés à
50 ans pour les habitants de ce village
éclaté en plusieurs hameaux à une
centaine de kilomètres de paris voté
front national c'est avoir le sentiment
d'exister mais pour monsieur le maire
c'est autre chose comme un défi à
relever il ya deux façons de regarder
l'avenir il y en a un qui serait du
désespoir et l'autre qui est dir est de
dire on va essayer de construire et pour
moi l'espoir c'est la communalité
essayer de la construire
sans oublier les gens de rozoy et des
autres villages bien sûr alors là c'est
un peu compliqué mais il ya une porte de
sortie mais il faudrait quand même
globalement que nos politiques se
rendent compte que ils ont des
territoires ruraux qui sont vraiment
désespérée alors on est reparti vers un
autre territoire désespérée la vallée du
cher
là les habitants ont voté en moyenne à
plus de 40 % pour le front national
selles sur cher la capitale du canton
fait office de frontière entre la
sologne et le berry les gens se savent
pas pour qui voter puisque de toute
façon les politiques ne représentent pas
vraiment voit finalement le problème il
l'a maintenant il ya pas de surprise
pour nous c'est surtout les gens du
voyage qui dérange donc j a pas de
surprise sur le vote du front national
les habitants ont un vrai sens qu'ils
ont des droits que nous nous n'avons pas
donc c'est une forme d'injustice est une
façon de donc de protester contre ça on
est envahi par les manouches à les gens
du voyage qui m'ont fiona qui sont très
bien et puis on a d'autres il se gare au
milieu de la rue il a par exemple ils
descendent de leur voiture pour acheter
leur paquet de tabac
les vélos roulent sur les trottoirs s'il
ya quelques canettes qui leur dit
quelque chose
une volée dasani t en face d'eux donc je
pense que ça aussi ça doit y faire c'est
que les gens du voyage évoque un
souvenir douloureux ici chacun garde en
mémoire les émeutes de l'été 2010 qui
avait ravagé la ville voisine de
saint-aignan
depuis les caravanes stationnent
toujours dans la vallée du cher et la
cohabitation est parfois difficile
au grand désespoir des élus locaux
la seule mesure qui a été prise c'est
l'air d'accueil mais une aire d'accueil
combat ça sur cher à a coûté plus de
déjà 300 à 350 milles euros
donc c'est un problème de moyens
également qui se pose pour qu'on
comprenne bien l'ampleur du problème
francis moche et tient à nous emmener
sur place là nous sommes à l'ère
d'accueil de ce chercheur il ya huit
emplacements et ça comprend seize
caravanes assez complet très complet non
loin de l'air d'accueil d'autres
caravanes sur un terrain qui est la
propriété des gens du voyage mais le
maire nous montre aussi ce parking d'une
entreprise en liquidation squatté depuis
plusieurs semaines enfin il tient à nous
faire rencontrer le propriétaire d'un
garage automobile à l'entrée de sakho
dans la mer c'est nous avec nos clients
on entend sans arrêt gens qui disent ah
bah tiens vous avez vos campeurs alors
moi je vois un terrain vert qui est bien
mais c'est bien joli mais il y aura ce
sera jamais occupé puisque de toute
façon il ya toujours des des caravanes
qui viennent s'installer malgré tous vos
efforts je le reconnais mais moi j'en
aura jamais de voisins côté on n'aura
jamais une entreprise qui va venir
s'installer c'est pas possible enfin je
je moi aussi d'ailleurs
alors l'ampleur du vote frontiste une
réaction somme toute normal pour ce
citoyen je suis même pas surpris je
dirais même que à la limite à entendre
ce que l'on entend ça aurait dû au
premier tour il aurait dû passer parce
que
là malheureusement on a l'impression
vraiment qu'on est lâché par la
préfecture par les par les autorités des
soirs où je me pose des questions je me
dis bon
désespérant on peut rien y faire
puis vis-à-vis de la population la
population ne comprend pas il faut
chaque fois ce justifié on souhaite à
fait de la crise
l'impuissance des élus locaux
un constat partagé par tous à commencer
par la conseillère départementale du
canton nos têtes de deux parties ont une
grande une grande responsabilité
à force de vouloir faire du
politiquement correct de ne plus appeler
un chat un chat
on s'éloigne de la réalité on s'éloigne
du problème des habitants et on est à
côté de la plaque
on est complètement ne répond plus aux
besoins c'est comme une entreprise qui
va fabriquer quelque chose qui ne se
vend pas c'est exactement la même chose
elle va couler des élus qui ne peuvent
rien faire et qui se renvoient la balle
mais que propose réellement le front
national nous avons rencontré l'une des
candidates locale nous sommes le seul
parti qui de toute façon montre que
certains projets ne sont pas réalisables
dans le sud du département
mais vous avez des solutions celui ci
un peu plus loin dans la vallée les
caravanes des gens du voyage ont disparu
nous arrivons à châtre sur cher le front
national est là aussi la première force
politique
le long de la route qui coupe le village
une enfilade de panneaux à vendre
plusieurs dizaines de commerces et de
maisons ne trouve pas preneur
et c'est toute une jeunesse qui
n'arrivent plus à se projeter dans
l'avenir
il ya un vote qui est très fort chez les
jeunes pour le front national qui n'ont
plus de perspective qui ne souhaite pas
partir non plus qu'ils sont très
attachés à leur territoire mais qui n'y
voient pas ou peu d'avenir etc ont
besoin de trouver des responsables à
leur situation et pour rubin voilà les
responsables je pense que c'est la
classe politique en général c'est
l'union européenne c'est c'est la presse
ces voix là il ya tout un tas de bouc
émissaire et l'impression que le front
national peut être la réponse à
à leurs problèmes un constat amer mais
pas question de se décourager
ça donne encore plus envie de se dire
que voilà ces jeunes qui habitent nos
petites communes on veut les garder mais
on veut les garder on voudrait les
gardes et serein et pas pas qu'il rêve
de barbelés aux frontières ou de revenir
au franc à 25 ans on doit pas rêvé à ça
mais quand on a rêvé à ça justement
est-il possible de faire marche arrière
pour le savoir nous sommes partis bien
plus au nord à dreux un coeur de ville
accueillant avec ses rues piétonnes son
église et son marché nous honnêtement
marine même viendront on aime bien on
était à dreuilhe à 50 ans on était en
campagne avec elle est en campagne
aurier mais l'histoire de dreux n'a pas
toujours été un long fleuve tranquille
en 1983 la ville est sous tension
l'immigration est atteint un taux record
de 40 % les populations sont regroupés
dans des quartiers ghettos sur les
plateaux tout autour du centre ville
pour la première fois en france le front
national fait irruption sur la scène
politique
en entrant à la mairie de dreux dreux
dont le nom sera longtemps associé au fn
comme nous le raconte valentino gants
bhutto chef d'entreprise et secrétaire
du ps en eure-et-loir
dreux avait une sale image en france
d'ailleurs même à l'international un
dreux avait été marqué c'était quand
même la première vie vous il y avait une
une peau une cogestion avec le front
national et la droite de toute l'europe
d'après-guerre non c'était avant une
image très forte qui est resté marqué et
qui est qu'ils posaient qu'on avait du
mal d'ailleurs à trouver des entreprises
que vous voulez investir sur dreux des
salariés qui vous laisse à venir
s'installer sur dreux et puis à chaque
fois qu'on sortait on devait justifier
que notre vie n'était pas à l'image de
ce que mettait en avant l'ascension du
fn à dreux s'est faite en partie grâce à
un couple emblématique
marie france et jean pierre stirbois qui
déjà il y a plus de 30 ans avait fait du
communautarisme leur cheval de bataille
à cette époque là il y avait quelques
problèmes sur les plateaux avec les
personnes d'origine étrangère
ça s'est beaucoup calmé dreux est re
devenue une ville calme ce qu'elle a
toujours été auparavant
voilà donc c'est je pense que c'est pour
ça aussi que le front national a chuté
sur le rouge est parti du front national
donc dans les années 80 et puis après
j'ai laissé tomber parce que la précitée
dégourdir des scellés trop en quoi c'est
allé trop loin moi quand on voit savoir
s'il est apte ou voilà autrement
quelques pas il faut le contribuable il
faut le faire quelque chose vous ça vous
rassure que le fn est quand même chuté
dans cette ville où vous habitez
c'est vrai moi j'avoue je vous achète ça
fait ça fait trois ans j'étais invité à
manger un couscous atypique c'est un pas
de chez nous contre musulmans chez moi
je suis du fn et mon fils et mike une
algérienne à dreux aujourd'hui chacun
fait des efforts conscients de la
nécessité de vivre ensemble le fn est
resté cinq ans à la mairie mais depuis
ils peinent à convaincre les gens plus
maintenant s'aperçoivent que quand ils
sont dans une municipalité
ben c'est pas forcément mieux gérer une
honte et voilà je pense qu'il n'y a pas
de je pense que sur le cas d'un dans le
cas de dreux on avait vraiment des
problèmes avec typiquement les sites et
les gens pensaient que ce serait une
solution qui sont pas forcément une
solution ne s'est pas séparé goya cas où
on règle les problèmes
aux dernières élections le vote
frontiste est resté ici au dessous de la
moyenne nationale à 24%
nous rencontrons des militants de la
première heure plutôt désabusé un
changement de population à dreux il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont qui sont
partis et puis des des gens qui
voletaient donc front national il y
aussi beaucoup il ya aussi beaucoup de
migration et avec les dans les dernières
décennies et beaucoup de d'immigrés qui
ont acquis la nationalité française et
qui justement vote et on constate
d'ailleurs dans les quartiers qui sont
assez concentré en immigrés et ça ne
font pas les voix qui sont favorables au
front national en remportant la mairie
il ya 20 ans face à la candidate fn
marie france stirbois gérard hamel
toujours à la tête de la ville a compris
qu'il n'y avait pas de temps à perdre
il y avait des quartiers difficiles à
vivre avec des grands ensembles à des
choses comme ça je me suis très vite
attaqué à la problématique de la
rénovation urbaine on est
des villes les premières qui ont
souhaité avec jean louis borloo faire
retransformer ses quartiers pour
redonner un cadre de vie dans les
quartiers
évidemment ça a payé comment voulez vous
après on retire en faisant toute
critique systématique sur des sujets que
qui faisait les qu'il faut et qui
faisait des beaux jours du front
national les militants frontistes quant
à eux accusent le maire de clientélisme
gérard hamel dans les quartiers quand on
a hésité sur les marchés ah ben tu veux
quoi dans moi ton nom demain tu veux
quoi ils donnent ils donnent près 20 des
électeurs bon à un moment on se dit on
donne on donne on peut pas toujours
donné aussi que les gens votent pour
vous parce que je pouvais leur donner
quelque chose mais pour vos idées lui
c'est pas des idées je te donne si tu
veux que je te donne n'empêche la
recette hamel porte ses fruits
il n'y a plus de permanence du front
national à dreux et le parti de marine
le pen n'a jamais retrouvé ses scores
des années 80 il faut que les politiques
soient beaucoup plus concret et qu'il
soit beaucoup plus lisible
aujourd'hui des discours on en a à
longueur de semaine à longueur de
journée ce sont des beaux discours qui
ne sont pas suivies d'effet donc je sais
pas si nous sommes un exemple nous on a
essayé d'être concret d'être pragmatique
et surtout de se donner les moyens et de
faire sans trop qu'on parle de nous
aujourd'hui je suis fier qu'on parle de
la ville de drogue différemment mais
c'est tout le travail d'une équipe ses
vingt ans de travail et on continue à
tenir ses promesses et agir
ce serait donc la solution pour contrer
les votes extrêmes
pas vraiment une nouveauté en attendant
le front national progresse et attire
toujours de nouveaux électeurs dans les
campagnes